duisburg bei nacht als wir hier mit
unseren recherchen beginnen treffen wir
immer wieder auf frauen aus westafrika
sie verkaufen ihre körper 30 euro für
schnellen sex woher kommen die frauen
und warum müssen sie sich prostituieren
offen reden will keine nach langem
zögern ist eine frau aus nigeria bereit
anonym zu sprechen sie nennt sich
precious sie sei zur prostitution
gezwungen worden erzählt sie
mein leben war nur foltern weine folter
ich war nicht frei ich hatte keine
rechte
musst du nur machen was mir gesagt wurde
ich habe von morgens bis abends befehle
bekommen ich musste mit vielen männern
schlafen ich war praktisch eine sklavin
und das ist doch kein leben
precious berichtet dass sie weg wollte
aus der armut nigerias menschenhändler
hätten sie über libyen ins ruhrgebiet
gebracht jetzt soll sie ihre schulden
für die kreise zurückzahlen
ich musste das alles tun um den
schleuser zu bezahlen den haben wir
nigeria getroffen und er hat uns
geholfen heute lebt der in italien
frauen seien 35.000 euro und wenn sie in
europa angekommen sind sollen sie dieses
geld abarbeiten
bochum ermittler uli bercks kennt solche
geschichten der polizist deckte eines
der größten menschenhändler netzwerke
deutschlands auf
der achse ist telefone abhören und
setzte verdeckte ermittler ein so konnte
er ein netzwerk aufdecken das von
deutschland über italien bis nach
nigeria erreicht ende 2009 10 wurden
sechs täter verurteilt die arbeiten von
bochum aus mit nigerianischen bankern in
frankfurt zusammen und mit schleusern in
italien libyen und nigeria hier sieht
man den reiseweg ausgehend von benin
city in nigeria seine reise muss man
sich vorstellen dort ungefähr vier bis
sechs monate wo die mädchen dann
teilweise auch währung ausgesetzt sind
und wurst angst vor vergewaltigung
teilweise auch vergewaltigung sind
haben stattgefunden
in deutschland angekommen übernehmen
dann zuhälter innen das ausbeuterische
geschäft so genanntem adams die
kontrollieren ob die mädchen auf den
strich gehen ihre schulden abarbeiten
die bei dampf machen gemeinsame sache
mit gut organisierten kriminellen banden
aus der nigerianischen heimat die verben
junge nigerianerinnen an und schleusen
sie mit falschen dokumenten bis nach
deutschland
versucht ein mädchen zu flüchten spüren
sie es auf und schrecken auch nicht vor
folter zurück
man muss schon sein das hat uns
eigentlich schon selber rascht weil die
doch sehr sehr gut organisiert und
strukturiert waren arbeitsteilig
vorgegangen sind über im international
kontakte verfügten und sich aber auch
hier gut bewegen konnten auch precious
lebt in ständiger angst hat sich aber
bisher nicht getraut zur polizei zu
ihren sie versteckt sich vor den madames
und dem menschenhändler der will immer
noch 33.000 euro von hier
das hat nicht aufgehört er macht das
weiter er hat mir gesagt solange er am
leben ist wird er dafür sorgen dass er
sein geld vollständig zurückbekommt
vieles deutet darauf hin dass die
verurteilten schleuse aus bochum
mitglieder einer besonders berüchtigten
bande waren der schwarzen axt einer der
drahtzieher ist weiter auf freiem fuß
peter s wir machen uns auf den weg in
seiner heimat nigeria
so noko da war ein ermittler trifft uns
am flughafen von lagos lagos ist das
wirtschaftliche herz westafrikas nigeria
eines der erdölreichsten länder der welt
doch der reichtum kommt vor allem einer
kleinen korrupten elite zugute so rum
und ottawa hat zahlreiche informanten in
der szene er selbst ist mitglied einer
geheimen jet gruppe in der sie schleuser
und menschenhändler austauschen viele
der vorwahlen sind europäisch
[Musik]
nicht nur verbindungen nach deutschland
ihr nicht reicht bis nach dubai indien
italien sowie russland
es ist ein unglaublich stark denn sie
sind alle ähnlich gleichen
machenschaften verwickelt
in einem ruhigen straßencafé zeigen wir
dem nigerianischen ermittler noch einmal
die bilder der verurteilten täter aus
bochum und ihrer mutmaßlichen komplizen
aus nigeria solon ist nervös wegen
unserer recherchen die zentrale person
auf der liste peter es sei ein
gefürchteter krimineller mit guten
beziehungen bis ins politische
establishment
die realität sieht so aus wenn ein
krimineller erfolgreich ist dann hat er
auch viel geld und kommt deswegen auch
davon
ganz besonders in diesem teil der welt
er geht also zu jemandem von den
sicherheitsbehörden und sagt bei euch
wird gegen mich ermittelt und ich möchte
dass du dich darum kümmert egal wie
bringen es einfach in ordnung hier ist
das geld
wir fahren nach berlin city nigerias
hochburg des menschenhandels hier wurde
der geheimbund schwarze axt mitte der
70er jahre gegründet von hier stammen
die meisten opfer und die sächsin bochum
verurteilten täter außerdem soll peter
es einer der mutmaßlichen drahtzieher
hier unbehelligt wohnen
ermittler solomon kann ein anonymes
treffen arrangieren mit einer mann der
sich kingsley nennt und behauptet er sei
ein mitglied der schwarzen axt
für mich ist die bruderschaft etwas
gutes
[Musik]
das ist die bruderschaft die gegen
unterdrückung kämpft sie sorgt dafür
dass sich niemand so leicht
einschüchtern kann
also deiner meinung nach ist die gewalt
und die qualen die er den mädchen an tut
etwas gutes es ist für dich also okay so
etwas zu tun
wenn ein mädchen das nicht auf die reihe
kriegt oder sich weigert ihre madame das
geld zu zahlen kannst du das doch nicht
einfach hinnehmen und so jemanden geben
der sie dann durch füttern muss
ich verstehe wenn sich eine madame
gemeldet und sieht er sagt eines der
mädchen weigere sich ihr das geld zu
zahlen und sie möchte dass du deswegen
leute folter ist dann machst du das
eine mal dann kam ich bin nach richtigen
egal ob sie in holland in italien oder
wo auch immer ist wenn
ein mädchen stur ist dann wird ihre
familie gefoltert
der mann der hier vor uns steht stellt
durch die macht des länderübergreifenden
netzwerks in nigeria sicher dass seine
zwangsprostituierte in bochum oder
duisburg auch wirklich anschaffen geht
durch die bedrohung ihrer angehörigen
die nigerianischen behörden scheint er
nicht zu fürchten und deutsche
strafverfolger sind weit dann fragen wir
kingsley nach peter es der
menschenhändler der in deutschland von
der polizei gesucht wird
ja das ist peter er ist ein alter
schleuser ein schleuser mit guten
verbindungen in libyen
und der ist also groß im geschäft mit
dem menschenhandel
[Musik]
sie nehmen jedes mal 25 mädchen manchmal
kommt er nach big city nimmt sogar 30
mädchen sucht ruhig nach ihm er hat ein
großes haus hier er ist ein großer
bosnien
und er ist selbst ein mitglied der
schwarzen axt
ja erst ein mitglied ein ranghohes
mitglied
kingsley führt uns bis in das viertel in
dem peter es wohnen soll doch wir müssen
die dreharbeiten abbrechen peter es hat
von unseren recherchen erfahren es ist
zu gefährlich hier weiterzumachen
zurück in deutschland
kommissar olli derks hat den
nigerianischen menschenhändlern rund um
bochum einen schlag versetzt doch er ist
sicher solange männer für billigen sex
zahlen wird es weiter zwangsprostitution
geben
die sind hier nicht freiwillig und die
stehen unter starkem wirtschaftlichen
druck und die econ sich auch und die
würde lieber normales schönes
leben in ihrer heimat führen oder das
sollte man schon mal im hinterkopf
fahren wenn man 30 euro bezahlt
[Musik]